Starship Troopers was a movie. I watched when I was eight years old and I thought it was a pretty cool sci-fi movie
but what I didn't know was that it was one of the most
misunderstood movies ever. my eight-year-old self will be completely
surprised. Starship troopers a dumb space war movie Starship Troopers a brilliant satire of military propaganda
Starship Troopers a movie that misunderstood the novel he was parodying and then got misunderstood for what it was parodying Starship Troopers
war is stored in the balls
Hello everybody it's me
Lately, there's been a lot more articles talking about Starship Troopers as in the light of we got it all wrong
How could we have been so blind you're all a bunch of fools, you do not understand. It was a joke Wow
I'm DoiNg mY paRt
I'm DoiNg-- your mom
(Adults laughing at a 9 year old)
Maybe in retrospect. It's easy to point out. How overly the top the satire is but
Looking back at reviews at the time, It seems like a lot of people just didn't get it. The exact words are the text
But do you understand it?
Do you believe it? So what really is being misunderstood here and why? let's investigate. Would you like to know more?
(The making of Pewds army of 9 year olds)
Citizens rule people making a better tomorrow
The movie starts off with these military propaganda films and it's really during these times that it should have been obvious
They're basically spelling out for us
Heyyy
It's satire
the story follows John Rico and Carmen Ibanez
I mean just a look at these two, these characters look like they came straight out of a Beverly Hills TV show and
That's the point
Rumor has it that the director purposely selected these
Actors to just look that part to make war look attractive and all these pretty people are fighting
This idea is also reinforced through just how the film looks it's not your ordinary, Gritty alien type of sci-fi.
It's-it looks and it's shot like a high school rom-com from the 90s
During one of their final classes, The teacher is explaining why only what's called citizens are allowed to vote
Why are only citizens allowed to vote but we're not really listening because we're distracted by the flirting and playfulness
Between Rico and his girlfriend they've seen as a perfect example on how this movie could get over people's head
Despite at times feeding the message over you with a stick
I dunno
When school is over they sign up for their military duty to become citizens
But before breaking apart, they make a promise to stay together
Let's make a vow
No matter what, we'll always be friends (I saw what you did there)
Rico joins the infantry force
Ibanez joins to Starfleet during one of Rico's training exercises, He pushes it too far and an accident occurs
Medic!!!!
(Pewds chuckling)
Pretty sure he's dead mate, pretty sure
to break down the story to the bare minimal, when Osiris gets destroyed in an alien attack "Buenos Aires has been wiped off the Earth"
Ibanez ends up with another guy she meets at Starfleet.
and Rico ends up with another girl that was all over him during high school. During the attack of alien space planet she then dies
Very tragic along with Ibanez new boyfriend who gets his brain sucked out. We don't need to show that
Honestly, it's pretty gross
the brain bug gets captured and since it controls all the other bugs the battle has been won and they reached a
amazing conclusion that
"It's aFraiD"
It's afraid, it's afraid everybody who would have thought
So there they are together back again just like in the beginning but they're really not with who they want to be
It's more of a well, I guess our
Boyfriend and girlfriend died. So here we are and the message of the stories and all we won the war is over. It's
We won but we must keep fighting any
Banas and Rico is the figurehead of this next generations of Fighters. Just like it will just keep going and keep going
Come on you Ape!! you wanna live forever???
When the movie came out it got terrible reviews and ratings in America
We were accused by the Washington Post of being neo-nazis
The director says, also pointing out how in England they seem to have understand the joke
This movie is meant to be an exaggeration of America they're
We are always right attitude to war which is probably why it flopped in the US and was a hit
Everywhere else in the world. One of the reviews that I could found that gave it two stars said this want to know more
Yes, I did
I was particularly intrigued by the way
the bugs had evolved organic launching pods that could spit their spores into space and could also fire big globs of
Unidentified fury matter at the attacking spaceships since they have no technology
These abilities must have evolved along Darwinian lines to say this severely tested theory of evolution is putting it mildly
This is the point of the film if you look at the attack of Buenos Aires
First of all, that guy is not from Buenos Aires
You see the footage of the meteor you see the fires you see all the things you don't see any bugs
You don't see any evidence of an actual attack. The Society of Starship Troopers is completely dependent on war to function
They and therefore they need an enemy to function
and for example when the meteor attacks
Rico is more sure than ever that he wants to fight against the bug when in reality
it was probably just a regular meteor a movie like this will probably never exist today because of how
Carefully edited and selected they are by the studios and I do think it's a fantastic film and if you haven't seen it
I definitely recommend watching it and and maybe it's time for a rewatch as well
But there's another side of the story that seemed a lot of times untold the book while
99% of movies based off novels that tend to be as close as possible to resemble its source material
To appease fans or the author this films basically pulls down its pants and unloads their biggest dump
It could possibly give on this novel
The only thing the movie really borrows from the novel list of bugs and the names of the characters in the novel
In fact, there's barely any action in it
there's only really one fight and the director of the filming said said that I stopped after two chapters because it was so
Boring, it is really quite a bad book
I asked Edie Newmeyer to tell me the story because I just couldn't read the thing this kind of annoys me or
Anyone being a fan of the novel really because despite me maybe not agreeing with everything
The novel says it has a lot of interesting things to say
It's basically a parody that got misunderstood and it still misunderstood what he was trying to parody
So are we back at this source material? I've never seen anything like this. It's so weird. It's so confusing
Highland the author's politics are difficult to point to because a lot of times he just seemed to enjoy playing around with ideas
There without a doubt provocative
but that's what make this a classic novel Heinlein wrote Starship Troopers because he thought America was getting soft and the bugs is flat-out a
description of a communist society if you're looking for an epic space sci-fi battle of man between bugs
Reading this you'll definitely be disappointed
Here's some themes that was discussed in the novel when the teacher in the beginning scene that talks about civic duty
He discusses that anything that is given to you has no inherent value if it's given for free
Which is why only what is known as citizens is allowed to vote
You could give someone an award without having them to work for it, but it wouldn't be worth the same to that person
hyaline felt the same about voting
It shouldn't just be handed down to you democracy is something we fought for?
But you won't appreciate it if it's handed down for free
I'm not saying I endorse his idea of having to perform military service to vote
But seeing how younger people are less and less inclined to vote
Pokemons going to the polls isn't really making anyone go to the polls
The teacher also discusses violence and importance of it in this society
Something given has no
Value look when you vote you are exercising political
Authority you're using force and force
My friends is violence
When the movie depicts violence as the ultimate source of conflict solver you laugh because it's silly it's dumb and it's over-the-top
But I wonder what the city fathers of Hiroshi would say about that
you
They probably wouldn't say anything Hiroshi mo was destroyed, correct?
What the fuck
Actually, why laughing we're turning a blind eye into history and maybe then it's not so funny
Punishment is a very long important part of the novel
It explains House punishment is vital to this society that we learned right and wrong from punishment man has no moral instinct
He is not born with moral sense. You were not born with it. I was not and a puppy has none
We acquire moral sense when we do through training experience and hard sweat of the mind
Last but not least the novel makes a very long case for why you should join the military
It feels like Heinlein wrote this to inspire young people and that Rico's character growth
Going from a boy to a man is a reflection of his own the novel makes a case. That veterans should run
Society because they know what's best for mankind
They can make decisions that are tough where one person gets to suffer for the better of the masses while in today in our society
We're hyper focused on individuals the outcry of one person could have a massive effect on everyone
I directed the Department of Defense and Pentagon to immediately begin the process necessary
to establish a space force
as the sixth branch of the Armed Forces we must have
American dominance in space.
A lot of us look at war today as something that we moved away from we avoid it because we know better now
But do we really?
The society and starship troopers needed war for its society to function
But within its context it might even be justified but within ours
maybe not pffft
Hope you guys enjoy this video. Leave a like if you did and I'll see you with another one tomorrow. Goodbye
*Sick Music*